here's what would happen if we nuked the  Mariana Trench  first of all to get the biggest nuclear  bomb ever made down 11 kilometers to  Challenger Deep the deepest point in the  trench you'd have to protect your bomb  from the high underwater pressure you'd  need to use a special pressure vessel to  transport your bomb at the moment of  detonation a bubble of hot steam would  expand rapidly in just a few seconds it  would cover an area of about one  kilometer there'd be a huge bulging  bubble on the surface of the water this  bubble would expand and contract for a  few Cycles  no neighboring cities would be wiped out  but you might see Rising temperatures  and hurricanes the turbulent water and  radioactive material would have adverse  effects on marine life bright light from  the explosion could blind or kill deep  sea fish  I don't really see the point of doing  this but